going to be announcing some tour dates
soon thank you Ted all right if you're
looking to make healthy changes in the
new year look to plant forward eating
registered dietitian Mia sen shares
mostly plant-based breakfast lunch
dinner and snack recipes that are easy
to make and will save you time and money
in the grocery store
hey Las Vegas now if you're looking for
a realistic and budget-friendly way to
clean up your diet in the new year look
no further than going mostly plant-based
Whole Food plant-based diets are on the
rise because research shows that they
may help ward off chronic disease all
while supporting everything from immune
health and gut health to Hair Skin and
Nails I have simple mostly plant-based
meals and snacks that you can make
starting with breakfast when making the
transition to a mostly plant-based diet
an easy place to start is with whole
grains at breakfast overnight oats are
an easy make-ahead breakfast that
essentially Cooks itself in the fridge
overnight and is ready to grab and go in
the morning in my new book mostly
plant-based I share how to make an
overnight breakfast 12 different ways to
a jar simply add a half cup of rolled
oats two teaspoons of chia seeds two
teaspoons of pure maple syrup a fourth
teaspoon of pure vanilla extract a
fourth cup of plain yogurt or non-dairy
yogurt and a half cup of unsweetened
almond milk give it a stir and top with
your desired toppings in the morning
such as sliced bananas walnuts and
cinnamon cinnamon apples and raw pecans
or blueberries and lemon zest next take
the guesswork out of lunch with make
ahead salad jars using my salad jar
formula and whatever ingredients you
have on hand start with two tablespoons
of dressing at the bottom of a 24 ounce
jar and layer with a half cup of animal
or plant protein 1 cup of dense firm
crisp veggies a half cup of soft
delicate veggies or fruit a half cup of
cooked whole grains two tablespoons of
fat such as nuts seeds or cheese and a
handful of leafy greens pour it out onto
a plate to enjoy for a plant-based snack
with a crunch try my chickpea popper six
ways transform the can of chickpeas
sitting in your pantry into your next
addicting sweet or savory plant protein
packed snack simply toss your cooked
chickpeas with olive oil and salt and
bake for 25 minutes add 425 degrees
Fahrenheit then toss with your
seasonings of choice such as everything
bagel seasoning garlic powder and herbs
or nutritional yeast for cheesy flavor
without the cheese and finally with the
benefits of hands-off cooking easy
cleanup and endless nourishing
combinations sheet pan meals are sure to
become a staple and your lazy weeknight
dinner rotation this sheet pan formula
for my book mostly plant-based is a
great guide to help you use up
whatever's in your fridge and check off
your food groups to make you'll need six
ingredients non-starchy veggies your
protein of choice such as chicken or
tempeh seasonings oil and a carbohydrate
Source these sheep and fajitas follow
that formula simply toss the veggies and
protein with oil and taco seasoning
spread out onto a single layer on a
baking sheet and bake for 20 minutes
tossing halfway through served with warm
tortillas I hope you enjoyed these
mostly plant-based recipes for more you
can follow me on Instagram at Nutrition
By Mia and check out my new book mostly
plant-based available on Amazon at
Barnes Noble and wherever books are sold